je suis dans un immeuble du 4e
arrondissement de la capitale derrière
cette porte clara bouaziz elle a perdu
son papa décédé en avril 2020 des suites
du coc vide
bonjour bonjour clara merci nous
recevoir faire a dit nous racontez nous
ce qui vous est arrivé
bon alors ce qui nous est arrivé
s'est passé au début de la la première
partie de l'épidémie mon frère ma mère
mon père on m'attrape locaux vides vers
mars et ils ont été malades
hospitalisés mon père est décédé du coc
vide si vous le voulez nous pouvons
continuer
car à comment s'est déroulée la prise en
charge de votre papa qu'ils sont venus
ils sont constater que ma mère et mon
père était malade et ils n'ont pris que
mémère pourquoi ton séparer ce couple de
personnes âgées malades tous les deux on
les a séparés ils étaient mariés depuis
60 ans et mon père a préparé les
affaires de ma mère pour aller à
l'hôpital et on a laissé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après alors
après j'ai rappelé on a rappelé deux
jours plus tard
pour mon père parce qu'il se plaignait
de ne pas bien respirer et mon père
détester l'hôpital dont il n'avait
jamais été à l'hôpital
et là il m'a dit non non je crois que il
faut fouiller les là et
donc on a appelé la préparer ses
affaires et il est parti à l'hôpital
votre papa et transporté à l'hôpital
et là qu'est ce qui se passe je ne sais
pas si c'est le troisième jour le
quatrième jour on va lui faire une
piqûre est là cette piqûre cette
injection à va être fatale c'est une
injection d'anxiolytiques et de
morphiniques vous avez pu dire au revoir
à votre papa non non non je je vais pas
dire boire on nous appelait en nous
disant que ça y est il allait partir
mais ça mon frère sont allés moi j'ai su
balai dans ce jeu je n'y croyais pas que
vous dire je voulais pas dit non je
viendrai pas parce qu'il ne va pas
mourir je la connais mon père redonne
vie à tous mon père vous pouviez lui
donner trois plantes qu'ont trouvée
morte yves un mois après boulet elle
était là avec des
floraisons quoi un objet cassé et
comprenait vite ou reprenent évitant des
pas possible que mon père meurt et on
peut dit l'aurait pas dû mourir ça c'est
un fait c'est sûr et certain
qu'est ce qu'il ya au-delà du coc vis du
virus
c'est la prise en charge qui a été
mauvaise selon vous c'est les premiers
soins
oui c'est mais c'est la prise en charge
de tout depuis le début c'est à dire que
quand l'épidémie arrive personne ne nous
prévient qu'il y à une épidémie personne
ne nous prévient de la contagiosité
personnes nous prévient du danger qui à
les masquer il ya les tests donc vous
vous demandez pourquoi avoir mis tant de
temps pour accéder au test pour qu'on
ait le droit de faire des tests tous les
jours rappelé mais s'il vous plaît les
tests les thèses et je disais mais
passer au delà n'attendez pas l'agrément
il faut sauver mes parents vont mourir
les gens sont en train de mourir
qu'est-ce qu'on attend qu'est ce qu'on
attend mais ces dépenses et des enjeux
pauline des enjeux politiques des enjeux
d'argent aussi 'cependant dans tous les
autres pays on se battait pour sauver
les citoyens ici on était dans des
palabres et des petits des petites
mèches basses de jeu politique et jeux
d'argent
pendant que les gens mouraient quoi tout
simplement c'est cette prise en charge
elle et elle n'est pas venue on aurait
dû être protégé par l'état vous avez
décidé d'intenter
une action en justice oui j'ai intentent
une action en justice contre la contre
l'état d'une part puis contre l'hôpital
et contre le samu wen jié dgd quelques
des documents s'y montrer mais si vous
n'aimez
vous ça c'est le premier document que
j'ai reçus en fait c'est ma convocation
pour la cour de justice vous avez déposé
trois plaintes oui contre l'état letton
spéciaux nul contre le stade oui oui
monde etc alors j'attends oui oui
j'attends qu'on trouve les responsables
j'attends que que justice entre
guillemets soit faite mon père est
décédé
malheureusement notre famille a subi une
déflagration
et elle n'est pas venu comme ça donc
voilà je veux que justice soit faite qui
est normal
vous êtes au travail vous commettez une
faute un impair
il y à des responsables où sont les
responsables